[Musique]
sous ces arbres de virginie se trouvent
les souvenirs d'un épisode fondateur de
l'histoire du pays
génération après génération c'est ici
que sont enterrés les membres de la
famille est au coeur des descendants des
premiers africains à poser les pieds
dans les treize colonies britanniques
qui allaient devenir les états unis
[Musique]
c'est important dit elle de souvenirs
qu'il y à quatre cents ans on les a
forcés à venir dans ce pays
comme une vingtaine d'autres passagers
leurs ancêtres isabelle et anthony était
originaire de ce qui est aujourd'hui de
l'angola
anna evans so what
leur arrivée à la fin ou 1619 marque
pour plusieurs le début d'un long et
sombre chapitre de l'histoire américaine
un système économique fondée en partie
sur l' esclavage qui a duré près de deux
siècles d histoire des luttes qui ce
mois ci ont été soulignés une
commémoration importante selon cette
historienne des endroits mais si dans
cette zone où les gens veulent pas
parler des saints où les gens se
plaignent par exemple de fait qui vont
visiter une plantation et qu'on parle de
l' esclavage
donc cette reconnaissance est un élément
important en ce moment pour de nombreux
afro américains l'art est donc important
et solennelle le mix cet homme dit par
exemple ressentir toutes sortes
d'émotions
au delà du devoir de mémoire il ya aussi
la réflexion
je pense que nous souffrons toujours des
effets de l' esclavage dit elle évoquant
notamment des enjeux de pauvreté encore
aujourd'hui aux états unis les familles
afro américaine peine à atteindre le
niveau de prospérité des familles
blanches dont la richesse est
généralement dix fois supérieur
comment y remédier en juin le concret a
tenu des audiences historiques sur un
débat qui persistent celui autour des
indemnisations financières aux
descendants d'esclaves
un outil qui selon certains permettrait
d'affronter des problèmes contemporains
combien de citoyens devraient être
compensés et quel montant serait
nécessaire aucune somme n'est
officiellement avancée mais des études
évoquent des centaines voire des
milliers de milliards de dollars
l'idée est donc loin de faire
l'unanimité tant chez les élus qu'au
sein de la population
les grains éléments positifs de tout ça
c'est des d'apporter ces débats dans
l'espace public
mais selon elle cette conversation est
bien loin d'être terminée mais la
réalité c'est qu'aucune des sociétés où
il ya lieu d esclavage soit aux états
unis chat dans les caraïbes france
français aux britanniques ou le brésil
aucun de ces endroits il n'y a jamais eu
un groupe d'anciens esclaves qui a
obtenu des réparations
au-delà du débat politique il ya aussi
la reconnaissance du rôle joué par les
ancêtres des tokyo et tous les autres
m
une histoire que la famille s'assure
d'entretenir avec soin
[Musique]